nous avons la chance d'avoir la matrice
républicaine je considère que c'est une
chance inouï euh que cette matrice euh
contrairement à ce que veulent nous
faire croire un certain nombre de
secteurs non seulement n'est pas désuett
ou même strictement française mais en
réalité correspond au défi de notre
temps c'est-à-dire qu'on a besoin
d'humanisme on a besoin d'universalisme
on a besoin de considérer d'abord les
êtres humains euh comme ayant une égale
dignité avant d'entrer dans la question
de leurs appartenances diverses et
variées euh et on a besoin et je
voudrais vraiment insister sur ce point
de ne plus avoir le logiciel de la
victimisation comme étant le logiciel de
lecture de la des rapports en société et
ce qui fait un tort considérable et ça
se voit dans le détail de chaque affaire
c'est que tout le monde veut être
toujours plus victime que le voisin et
que c'est dans cette surenchère de la
victimisation on a finalement un un une
course sans fin et qui est un petit peu
la clé de compréhension de beaucoup de
d'attitudes le
dans l'école de la 3e république le le
qui avait bien des défauts qui étai loin
d'être parfait mais il y avait
premièrement la foi dans le progrès de
dans le progrès en général et dans le
progrès par le système éducatif en
particulier et deuxièmement personne
cherchait à s'afficher comme victime de
quoi que ce soit là il y avait une
émulation qui était liée à la
méritocratie républicaine et qui était
favorable au plus faible et donc les
plus faibles ne gagnent rien à la
logique de victimisation il gagnent au
contraire à la logique d'égalité tout
simplement et d'universalisme ce sont
des choses un peu simples que je suis en
train d'énoncer mais elles sont
fondamentales tant qu'on ne sort pas de
ça le combat est un combat un peu face
face à la vague pour le coup c'est pas
le pas de vague mais c'est face à la
vague c'est-à-dire une vague d' de de
d'interprétation du réel qui ne va pas
et quand vous voyez détail de chaque
affaire y compris l'affaire pati vous
voyez bien le que la rhtorique de des
acteurs et notamment de certains élèves
c'est de de toujours se mettre sur ce
registre-là et cette et et tant que nous
n'en sortirons pas et donc pour en
sortir il faut encore une fois des
matrices intellectuelles c'est-à-dire
c'est des enjeux de débat public c'est
des enjeux d'enseignement c'est des
enjeux de de paradigmes qui sont euh
dans nos institutions et bien euh on
aura des des difficultés